عقد وزراء دفاع روسيا وتركيا وسوريا
مباحثات ثلاثيه في العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
بمشاركه قاده الاجهزه الاستخباراتيه في
هذه الدول وقالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في
بيان انه تم بحثه لحل الازمه السوريه
ومشكله اللاجئين والجهود المشتركه لمكافحه
الماء وصفه بالمجموعات المتطرفه على
الاراضي السوريه واضاف البيان انه في
نهايه المباحثات اشاره المشاركون الى
طبيعه البناءه التي جرت خلالها المباحثات
وضروره مواصله الحوار بما فيه مصلحه تحقيق
الاستقرار في سوريا
من اسطنبول مراسل الجزيره عامر لافي ومعنى
من موسكو مدير مكتب الجزيره زوور شاوش
ابداوا معك في اسطنبول عمل لافي واللقاء
الاول بين الوزيرين تركي والسوري منذ عام
2011 كيف كانت اصدقه اولا في تركيا وما
المؤمل منه
كانت واقعه هذا كان وقع هذا الخبر مفاجئا
وين كانت ارهاصات التقارب التركي السوري
انصحها وصفها موجوده اردوغان حتى لم
يستبعد ان يكون هناك لقاء على مستوى
الرؤساء ولكن ربما ليس في الوقت الحالي
سرعه تحقق هذا اللقاء هو هذه كانت
المفاجاه بالفعل وواضح طبعا ان هذه اللقاء
ان هذا اللقاء كان بسبب او استمرار ما
يمكن وصفه بالوساطه الروسيه التي حاله دون
تنفيذ تركيا لعمليه في الشمال السوري وفقا
طبعا لوزاره الدفاع تركيا هناك ثلاثه ربما
ان تطلق على هذا اللقاء بدايه الارهاب
اللاجئين واستمرار هذا النموذج وهذه
الصيغه من مباحثات اي الثلاثيه بين روسيا
وسوريا وتركيا بالنسبه للموضوع محاربه
الارهاب كما تقول تركيا طبعا هي معنيه بان
تزيل ما تسميه الشريط الارهابي على حدودها
الجنوبيه وتعني طبعا ان يكون هناك كيان
يعني يملك نوع من الاستقلاليه يتبع لوحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه والتي ترى فيها انقره
امتداد لحزب العمال الكردستاني الذي يهدد
امنه القومي اردوغان قبل يومين كان قد
تحدث عن انه هناك خطوات جديده كما وصفها
لتامين عدم يعني استقرار هذا الممر
الارهابي على حد وصفي وايضا تامين ال 30
كلم في العمق السوري الذي يتحدث عنها
المسؤولين الاتراك بشكل مستمر واضح ان هذا
اللقاء كان هو ما قصده اردوغان في هذا
الحديث طبعا همم وسائل الاعلام هنا
المراقبون هنا يتحدثون عن صيغ على ما يبدو
ان هناك توافق قريب قد يحدث بخصوصها همم
انقره معنيه بان يكون هناك وجود للنظام
على حساب حزب العمال الكردستاني كما تقول
ربما الصيغه في الرفعت كما يقولون سيكون
وجود كامل للنظام في عين العرب سيكون هناك
وجود مختلط للنظام والوحدات لكن كل هذه
التفاصيل الغير واضحه حتى الان بشكل كبير
وان كان الافلاك يعولون كثيرا على انجاح
هذه المباحثات لهذه الخطوه الامر الاخر
ربما المهم طبعا اللاجئين الاتراك لا
يريدون عوده اجباريه للاجئين السوريين
ولكنهم يريدون ذلك تعلمينا المعارضه
تستخدمها كوار قد ضغط على الحكومه في
الانتخابات القادمه لذلك المباحثات ركزت
على عوده وصفوها بالكريمه وفقا لمصادر في
وزاره الدفاع هنا
للمواطنه السوريين بحيث لا تتم ملاحقتهم
هناك في سوريا وبالتالي هذا سيشجعهم على
العوده الى بلادهم يصور ماذا تقول موسكو
بشان هذا اللقاء الثلاثيه او هذه
المحادثات الثلاثيه وكذلك يعني طبيعه
الدور الروسي همم فيها همم والذي جمع ما
بين تركيا وسوريا للمره الاولى منذ 11
عاما
طبعا هي انا روسيا استطاعت ان تجمع ما لم
يمكن كان ان يجتمع قبل 11 عاما اليوم
تمكنت روسيا براي على الاقل التصريحات
الاولى او تعليقات الاولى في وسائل
الاعلام من جمع قطبين مهمين في هذه الازمه
الازمه حول سوريا روسيا وتركيا على مستوى
وزراء الدفاع بمشاركه وزير الدفاع الروسي
همم جلسوا بشكل مباشر وبدعوا بنقاش قضايا
اساسيه متعلقه بالامن ليس فقط في شمال
سوريا
الاقليمي بشكل انعام بالنسبه لموسكو هي لا
تريد العمل العسكري لتركيا في الاراضي
السوريه خاصه العمليه العسكريه البريه هي
تريد ان تثبت ما تم التوافق عليه مع
الجانب التركي والايراني في منصه السنه
بالحفاظ على وحده وسلامه الاراضي السوريه
الاعتراض يعني النظام السوري لان هو فعليا
سلطه شرعيه همم في سوريا وهذا ما اليه
روسيا وربما الى حد كبير اا ناجح حتى سيما
وان ايضا لدى موسكو هواجيس فيما يتعلق
بمساله تسلم على الحدود تسلم على النظام
السوري لكابل الحدود مع تركيا هي امام ليس
بارسال عمليه معقده سيما وان قسم كبير من
ما بقي من قوات النظام هي متواجده فعليا
في مناطق همم خطوط جبهه مع تنظيمات معارضه
تدعمها تركيا ايضا روسيا تصفها بانها
تنظيمات ارهابيه يجب ايضا الانتهاء منها
وفوقها توافقات التي تمت بينها بوتين
واردوغان عام 2019 وبالتالي هي خطوه خطوه
مهمه تتعامل معها روسيا بشكل ايجابي كبير
وتعبيره انجازا مهما نحو طريق تخفيض
التصعيد في هذه المنطقه الحساسه على
الحدود السوريه التركيه من ناحيه ومن
ناحيه اخرى فتح باب ومجال لحوار اوسع بين
روسيا وتركيا وسوريا وتقارب سوري تركي
ربما يفضي الى نتائج كثيره ابراجها على
عجاله هي ان روسيا لا تريد البقاء
الامريكي في منطقه الجزيره السوريه في
شمال سوريا هذا المضى الامر هاجس كبير
بالنسبه لموسكو وربما هذا تقارب قد لا
يلقى اذان صاغ او ردود فعل همم
مؤيده في الاجانب الامريكي ولكن روسيا
بدون شك تريد ان تنهي ايضا الورقه الكرديه
بطريقه تلائم الاكرادي لحد كبير تلائم
تركيا وثلاء النظام السوري هو بحيث لا
يبقى ابدا اي تواجد للطرف الامريكي في تلك
المنطقه نعم نعم
من اسطنبول